okay hi everyone
we are looking at incremental language
development for
language we have a variety of topics
today as always
so first up improve date string parsing
and formatting
main ideas
write more freedoms that sounds deeply
political
um no what what um uh
go ahead uh okay nick do you want to
explain or should i
yeah so basically in addition to work on
making sure that date string parsing is
faster and supports more formats we also
want to take advantage of the fact that
we have some tools that can support
dates in different languages with
different writing scripts
and so right now we have this existing
option for date object and data object
like containers that basically says this
is the way the date should show up
it basically mimics the formats we allow
and date
string we have a futurized ref page
called date format new that kind of has
our proposal of how we would take
the additional flexibility of saying you
know
in addition to these elements i want to
say these elements are in spanish
or is there a language option or
something or what
yeah so rather than necessarily having a
language option we're trying to
basically flesh out there's a language
parameter basically and then because
particularly with dates but with
languages in general we run into
complicated
complicated cases like serbian where
it's common to write it either in latin
characters or cyrillic characters or a
lot of
indian languages have multiple writing
scripts trying to sort of
give a comprehensive way to spec out a
date format and say these are the
elements i want included
this is the language i want them in this
is the writing script if we need them
oh yeah this should be an association
this shouldn't be a random list with
with extra little pieces here
i mean i think this should be an
association and we should have sort of
a list of bank names for those that
are common association settings so to
speak
that correspond to uh
you know u.s standard dates european
standard dates whatever it is
you know and then um
but let me understand uh
why does it say the date formatting of
dates why didn't you say the formatting
of dates
um yeah it should be the formatting of
dates
okay but
so i think the point here is that we are
using this powerful library called icu
and they handle things via locales so we
are interpolating their locales to what
we had before in data stream
this elements language yeah i understand
so now we cover both things yeah
okay but i mean we have a locales issue
that is also an issue for our language
system
because you know language english local
whatever
i mean we have this mechanism and it's
been a mechanism that
has been supposed to be installed in the
front end for the spell checker
for things like british spell checking
and so on
right so that's tell discussion further
down okay
data and how to use your calls in more
general right so i mean if your question
is
could date format have an association
with a bunch of details about language
and script and all this kind of thing
and delimiters and all that the answer
is for sure
um
right yeah so so that's our proposal to
to support what icu does by extending
our language
to cover locales and fine but let's look
at locales in more general lte okay so
you're talking about this
from date string yes okay let me make a
comment about this
okay one of the things that i'm not
exactly thrilled about
is in dateless plot or in time series
that you know if you look under the hood
the ultimate coordinates that are being
used and this probably relates to the
whole datum issue and so on
um datums for dates issue and so on
is in the end the coordinate system is
absolute time
which is a really cruddy and an
unfriendly coordinate system but in the
end
you know like for example if i want to
place something in an epilogue of a
dateless plot
in the end i'm going to have to use
absolute time coordinates for the x-axis
what should we be doing about that
right so there are two things there
one it is done for efficiency because
yeah and the second thing is that the
internally date the date uh the plotting
functionality cannot understand
dates in general but i think this is
going to be changed via the scaling
functions
uh mechanism okay well that'd be nice
but the alternative would be
that there's a sort of datum for the
plot that allows you to to be able to
give and i don't know exactly how this
should be thought about but it allows
you and perhaps that's the scaling
function issue
to say these numbers that are just in
fractional days or something or whatever
it is
they are going to be you know yes i'm
going to use numbers because it's a plot
and i can do things like you know i do
i mean like like for example if i get an
interpolating function
i think it's you know interpreting
functions in the case where we might
have a
leap year or some weird or leap second
you know that's just a horrible mess
and i think by the time you know we've
got to ultimately turn
the time axis into numbers right
so but but my point is that maybe we can
have the option of turning them into a
more
civilized kind of number than just the
absolute time numbers
yes so in my opinion something
that works via scaling functions such
that you can specify independently in
both access that you want dates there
for example
the data plotting functions do not
support dates in the y-axis
no they don't right and that would be
something
yes absolutely well okay so you think
there's a separate solution for taking
this i see the scaling function is
basically something which already
does the two-way transformation between
dates to coordinates
and and back again to dates for labeling
exactly
so currently it can do any
transformation any function
so the idea is to generate that has to
have an inverse function doesn't it
uh you can specify i think both direct
and inverse
yeah okay so in this case you would have
to specify independently per
access that you want dates and then
something worries about any date
in any form you you well i think it's a
good solution
to right but i mean i would like to
point out that i don't know how scaling
functions plays with epilogue for
example
that i don't know that's a question for
brett yeah but we should we should
have that question answered okay
okay so from date string okay so wait a
minute
from date string is a new thing yes so
part of the motivation is right now
anything that except dates
will as input anywhere we'll accept date
strings
and also this form that is a list of a
date string and then a list of elements
that basically correspond to a date
format
and there are some complicated things
that go with how
date strings are parsed as input and
right now there's no real landing page
to put those on we either document them
on the 40 pages that have
dates or 40 ref pages that potentially
have dates as inputs and say in every
case this is how
you know these are automatic delimiters
that'll be interpreted
you know so right now if i say date
object
of the dates of a string it will do the
conversion right
right exactly this is basically a
special
you know there's no change in
functionality here versus
date object of a string but it gives us
the ability to document
more thoroughly you know specifically
when you're working with strings as
input this is how you can handle
different formats
this is the different elements that are
important
you know we cannot be totally thrilled
by this i mean
in in um uh
i'm not totally thrilled in my opinion
this follows
from absolute time which is a more
readable way of understanding what's
going on
than than just forcing everything
through the date object
sorry say that again so we have already
from
absolute time which is a function
dedicated to convert absolute times into
uh even though that would work if you
said date object of an absolute time
exactly yes but it's a more reasonable
way yeah all right okay
okay this will start that gap
okay um
okay sandra is asking is there a way to
get third
21st 17th of a month i think so
unless i'm very confused that's a
straightforward thing to get isn't it
i mean given a month right if i say okay
so
that's maybe i'm maybe i'm not
understanding or maybe there's something
i'm missing here
um if i say
january 2021
why did that not why did that turn into
a date object like that why didn't it
is that what we want it to do i guess
i guess we do okay how do i get the
third of this month
how do i get from this how do i get the
third day of that month
adding three uh i think two days
no but that's not the first of the month
that's the whole month that's all
yes but the operations oh i see thing
yes yes yes but that's actually turns
out not to be the question that that
sander was asking but
we'll get to his question in a minute
but i want to ask my question too
um uh my question here is how do i get
the third day of that month right
so perhaps nick has a better way what i
would do is to project this to a day
and then add two days so that that's
first
date or something of this is that right
is that what it is no it would be
just changing the generality today so
the date object of
of date so that would produce the first
date
yeah and then at two thanks
quantity today
okay all right let's address sanders
question
uh writing january 3rd
do we have a way to do that preferably
what time without specifying a year
i guess so yeah so that is more or less
what the
the date select date pattern or date
select criteria
are we can basically say that the month
is
january and the day is the third but we
don't have a notion of uh
effectively a headless date if that's
the question
well i mean can we get this is there
some way to get that format out
ah i see so we basically want an
inordinal
yeah day of month yes um that's just
something we should have we don't have
it right now
yeah we don't have it right now but
there's no reason we couldn't have
i mean we already have flexibility to
generate ordinal dates from
integer string etc so we could have
seems like that's just a missing thing
now but but that wouldn't be a string
i i know so i was about to address that
so the question is can it do a
superscript
and the answer is i think it's good
enough to do not a superscript
to do a superscript is is more luxury
i think we shouldn't bother remember
making sense
yeah we could potentially
yeah i mean maybe we could have a future
thing if there is
any place to put a non-string output for
a date format
not in a date format we could have it
from date value
actually there may be a unicode
character that is that superscript
that's another possibility which we
should check out
okay yeah i don't know offhand we can
certainly look into that yeah
i bet there is yeah we could just call
that
the ordinal day or something because
dave well ordinal day
would be ordinal day string and then
some kind of ordinal day
i don't know unicode or something but
perhaps that's too obscure
right if there's a i bet there is a
unicode character for that
yeah there's a problem probably not in
this meeting but in a future one
we'll look at a handful of new date
string elements that we want to add in
just from various things that are we
found that aren't
covered currently in our date string
elements framework but they're
largely peripheral things like this that
may be useful but
right now okay fine all right okay so
then
show granularity whether
so these this has got to be an
association we can't have string random
string options flapping around unless
unless i i think this is a very detailed
thing
that we should essentially be bank
switching
by a named you know category now
essentially what you're talking about
here
is like date themes yeah there are
so what we've sort of thought of is that
there are there are named date formats
or date standards so
iso 8601 is a big one that you know
specs out what the elements are what the
delimiters are
and you know it doesn't spell out any
names of months or days so there's no
language associated with it
but locales are something where when i
say i want a date
using you know british english
it will say okay the elements should be
in this order they typically have this
delimiter
it uses right so what you're saying is
there are
named string named themes
and then there is an association which
gives all the details
right and we can basically map any named
theme to an association and then if we
that's fine
have yeah i think you certainly
convinced me it
probably makes sense to just have an
association for these things yeah it's
too much of a mess
yeah um now
right but these these themes might
depend on
the on the local that's something nice
about them
well hold on a second this particular
case element element element
that's something
that and by the way the fact that you've
got this horrible ambiguity with double
double bracing those things is just
horrifying because
in fact it's ambiguous because we've
already got the list case where it isn't
double braced right
right so we can't really do that so
i think i mean the fact is there's an
additional thing here
which is some of these are our keywords
like hour minute
etc and some are not right which is
something we've kind of run into
in the past with you know if you say
date string and you list what elements
you want
if it's a keyword we use it if it's
anything else it just gets literally
inserted
which is why you can have arbitrary
delimiters yeah sure but but which is
nice but i mean
you know perhaps this is more like a
string template
where you know we might even have some
or
what what's a good example where
where we have a limited so i mean string
template will be one thing
um i mean this is really a date template
more than it is i mean that particular
thing is a date template
and in the association it could be named
as a date template
and possibly could be given in some kind
of um
more string template type form but this
is kind of the
l you know this is the cheap version of
how to do that
right just as another cheap version
would be quotes
you know british date or something
[Music]
does that make sense yeah i mean there
are
so the next subsection in the agenda
will show that british state can be a
little complicated
just because so this is the icu's
curated list of formats for each locale
um okay and so you know for a british
date there's a standard that they use
for a short one a medium one a long one
and a full one
full will typically include day of the
week but it is
locale dependent because some locales
don't include that or may include
all right so look look you know
i don't know the belize long is a little
bit weird
but i don't think it's necessarily
terrible
um
you know if what you want so so let's
take this for example
or let's take what's a good example
sweden here
okay great but it sure isn't called
wednesday in swedish
it is if you're using so this is
specifically these are just variations
for english
in different countries so there are a
number
of potential languages that
get used in sweden you know this is
basically the standard form for
writing dates in sweden using
using english okay but then so then
look if we say uh you know date format
arrow swedish
or something or sweden
well obviously we should use country we
should use entities right
date format arrow i see that's not going
to work
well i mean we could also use these
locations so the brennan key
that right the problem is that you first
choose the language and then you choose
in which country you are speaking that
language
so so that means this is well okay but
the local name en
underscore se you know we could support
that as a string name
yeah and i think you know if if we're
supporting locales it makes sense
to support that you know this is there
are a handful of standard locale
notations that you that are defined by
iso standards so so in the end that
should be a local
um uh entity type
yeah and then that's the last bullet
point in this subsection
is the current version of locales and
entity well do we really have them i
mean
they're not exposed so they're still
under development
they are in death mode yeah
okay yes this is something we developed
a long time ago that when we were
talking about supporting different
dictionaries in the front end but it
never went out because
we never supported that properly well
that's something we're working on
i think the pitcairn one is really
exotic how many people live in pitcairn
i don't know
um no that's not even though that must
be fun if they're like 20 people
and you can't have your own local okay
sorry go ahead
um yes so so we got this lead from from
the
cldr uh data so so that is used by icu
and it means that they have different
preferences in these
locals so there is some different
preference in bitcoin english than in
english from puerto rico for example so
that's why they have listed that
no i understand i understand completely
but i mean
so the basic point is the correct way to
do this
is using these locales to say date
format arrow
um local
right and
well you you sorry i think you should
say
which date you want so if it's long form
full form etc
and using this logo yeah well
so one of the things is in locale data
which we have a ref page for we've tried
to basically say if
you know we have these locales you could
potentially look up the various formats
to get the populated association we're
talking about having in date format
and we may have some convenience feature
that says
i want my date format to be japanese and
by default it says
okay a japanese date is the long form
and so it populates like this hold on
hold on hold on
what i'm imagining is that there is an
option just like there's a language
option
there would also be a language locale
option
well let me think about this for a
second hold on hold on let me think
about this
or should we have language be something
are all these really language locales
or are they are something else i mean is
these is this ultimately a language
locale
story liberian english for example
did you understand what i'm saying i
mean so because could we just make it
that the way you get this is you know
date format arrow
long or something language arrow
english liberia
you see what i'm saying yeah i mean i do
think that
rather than having a language locale or
a locale
option it potentially makes sense to
just have the language option
accept locales yeah that's what i'm yeah
that's what i'm saying
if they're presented as english paren
seychelles
yeah it's perfectly reasonable that's a
language
but it's a variant right and
localization that's happening
language because that's the minimal set
that defines a locale
okay so english here is that a local
or is that so that is language
so that is a locale that is just defined
there
for each language there is effectively a
generic locale that doesn't have a
country associated with it it will
basically
you know they're typically based on the
cldr data is a reference country that
says okay for english
we use basically the uk standard for all
of these things
i bet it's the us yeah but right you
know for serbia
[Laughter]
for english in particular that's a
special case because
and for spanish because they have a list
of countries that should default
to british english and countries that
should default to u.s
english for example i'm sorry who has
what are you saying so you're saying
okay look so in icu they have a list of
countries
that use that should default to u.s
english or should default to
british english in case they don't
define a basic
well so one possibility then for example
i understand so one possibility is that
we could say language arrow
and then a country entity and in some
cases it'll be completely obvious what
that means
right in other cases it may be ambiguous
in other words for a given country there
will be an official language but there
might be seven official languages
yeah if you say language goes to india
it's
going to be complicated i thought it was
hindi maybe it's english i don't know
what what um
um official languages i think
oh is that right okay well fine but i
mean then then we need a notation that
could be a list
language arrow a list of the country
and it's um and you know in the language
we're talking about
and that will be an alternative to
giving the um
uh you know the locale form the specific
locale entity
yeah so the main concern i have
with having it be specifically a
separate option
is that with dates in particular we have
to worry about the language both in
input and output potentially so if i say
this date object's language is spanish
we may run into questions about
an input date going into that do we
default it to spanish or do we have
a notation that says this input dates
format
is a short date in english but i want
the output to be
a long date in spanish
well i don't quite understand i mean
what what determines okay
what what ingests a date as an input
date from date string would it would
ingest a date as input right
yes okay date object is always the most
complicated case because
it needs it ingest dates as input
potentially and it generates them as
output
maybe maybe we should go to using from
date string as the
ingester and have from date string have
a second argument or something which is
the
or you know have that be the main place
where we have control over the input
and have data object be something that
is primarily controlling the output well
because otherwise we've got to have
input date format output date format
options for date object
right right this is sort of the
complication we ran into with
time zones where you know traditionally
a time zone
option specifies the output time zone
and your input time zone is your dollar
time zone
but for date object we have to
potentially handle objects that come in
with their own time zone
time zone in in the string or time zone
yeah i mean it's not only time zone on
the string but also
you need to be able to quote it as i
mean this time zone
right how do you do that
so a date object
there's basically a hierarchy within
data object of
a data object can take another data
object as an input and in that case
that already has a time zone associated
with it and will
carry it along unless you specify a
different one
if you give an input that has no time
zone it's just a date list or an
absolute time or a date string that has
no time zone
then we fall back to dollar time zone
and if it's something else you know if i
specify an explicit time zone then we
have to kind of handle one way or the
other so
i think well how do we handle it is it
an input time zone or an output time
zone
so if you the time zone
option to date object specifies the
output time zone
of the date object and will also be used
as the input time zone if there's no
other time zone specified so if i say
date object and provide a date list and
say time zone goes to
zero it will say okay this date was
given
in gmt and the output should also be gmt
but if the if the date string contained
a time zone
est or something yep then it would if
you
didn't specify an output time zone it
would inherit and keep that time zone
if you did specify one it would say this
time zone
is in the time zone the string specifies
and should be converted to the time zone
you say it should be
yeah the same way if you said date
object of now
and time zone goes to 12 it would
take the current time and convert it to
the target time zone
something important here is that until
now we were not able to extract
time zones from strings so this this
situation is new
yeah this is one of the new things that
the improved date string pricing
supports okay so look from date string
looks like it's it's got to exist
because it's really the thing that goes
you know
that unravels what you meant by that
date string so for example if you say
from date string time zone arrow blah
i'm assuming that that will assume
unless there is a time zone contained in
the date string
that will mean assume this time this
state string referred to this time zone
now and generate a data object with that
time zone as output
yeah and if you want a different time
zone then you say date object of that
thing
comma time zone arrow whatever and that
then generates
a um i mean time
converts either way yes
right okay but but so okay so let's go
let's go back around this
all right so what we've got here is a is
we're breaking this
into short medium long full as string
names
which would default to the current
dollar language
or dollar language i mean we probably
should have two
dollar symbols dollar language and
dollar language locale
i would think because they'll be used by
different functions
right right
yeah we've tried to sort of inventory
no for example we already have a
function that it's getting the language
and the country which is integer
integral name
[Music]
yeah we have the ability to populate a
locale
from the operating system um
right that's a good model for this
but does that get local or not
this should explain what language can
actually be
that this documentation needs to be
filled out
do you understand that documentation
yes i think yes
i mean i think in general the language
option should probably
work with locales this is pathetic this
this needs to properly document
this this is kind of annoying that this
is wrongly done
come on this needs a table that says
what kinds of things can happen there
okay go ahead what were you gonna say i
was gonna say up until now there hasn't
been a proper
representation of language locales again
this entity type is currently in dev
mode
i think it makes sense yeah it needs to
be
fleshed out and anything that accepts
language as an option
should take language locale because
minimally it can just extract the
language from it
there are some complicated cases that
currently use language where
they also potentially need to support
writing scripts so transliterate's a
function that
takes languages and interprets them but
really operates on writing scripts so
when you say
translate this from english to japanese
the language look called contains the
writing script or not
a it can contain it so each of the
languages have
default writing scripts and then in
cases where it's ambiguous
it will note both of them so serbian's a
case
bosnian is more exotic but it has three
i remember the one my my my few hours
that i spent in bosnia once
the the road signs were nice and exotic
um right so so wait a minute so how do
you specify that are there three locales
for
corresponding to bosnia for for roman
cyrillic
uh arabic yeah there may
be even more i'm not sure off-hand okay
okay but those
okay fine yeah so i think like india has
20 officials
yes okay so then then let's just
understand this
are these all being put a set of
potential settings for dollar language
could be a local entity that
is a subdivision of those things where
language arrow whatever
uh could be treated you know where we
will have a translator
that goes from a language locale down to
a language for functions that only
accept language and don't accept
language local
yeah i think that makes sense all right
so then we don't have to have a dollar
language local
we just have a dollar language yeah i
don't i can't
imagine there's any case where a
language option could not handle a
locale because a locale always has a
language associated with fine it just
has to be untangled
yeah okay all right so now what are the
questions that remain here
okay so let's go through again what
we're saying we're saying basically
that language locale
we then know what to do we then have
these these names short
medium long full for example
um there is or we have
this explicit template form
um or we have an association
right right now in the template form
these elements here are elements that
come from
um uh where do they come from they come
from properties of date format right
yeah so they're date string elements
that are all
there's a table on date string and a
table in
date value which uses the same element
names that basically says these are all
the possible
keywords
okay fine so these are the keywords
so and it's a bit unfortunate that
there's no
okay so probably we should support
verbatim as an option in that templating
mechanism just in case you want to write
weak
yeah as a word string yeah
okay
um
sander is is commenting on date string
is there a date convert function i can't
even remember
there's a time convert but there's no
date convert
like calendar convert or
well i'm not sure i mean i i mean you
know wednesday the 3rd of january
16 6 p.m whatever written out
i guess that that just corresponds to a
canonical internal date and then there's
another
yeah so it's pure formatting because the
internal representation is is invariant
under you know the different possible
choices of what you give as input
okay what else do we have to figure out
here
i think there is a global question here
about
whether to roll out these for the moment
only for dates
or more general so for example this
local data function
it's mostly dedicated to date
information at the moment
well wait wait wait local data is yet a
different thing here so this is
right so so we need a function that
reports information about the various
locales
why aren't those just properties of the
local entity
some they could potentially be there's
some specific
things like you know this date short
form
etc where we basically want to have a
mechanism to look up the association
that you'd give to date format
[Music]
that's a terrific computed property for
that entity
i don't think we should have local data
it looks like it's really just an entity
property story
that should be just properties of
the language local entities
make sense um
yes maybe an advantage of this is that
it will look up in to the library
to the local library yeah we could
certainly have alpha
another thing is that
and another thing is that you can invent
locals
i mean for example you can combine
english in peru which doesn't exist
because we don't have any variants
but this will automatically fall back to
the general links
to american english right
because someone could put that as an
input in for example in your browser you
you you can write exactly english
underscore peru for example that's not
supported
i don't understand i don't understand i
don't know this is okay
okay then it's not local data then what
you're specifying is a local object of
some kind
that would be the alternative what
you're proposing
is something where there's some kind of
you know just like molecules for example
are not all
entities you're saying that it will be
some kind of local object
that you could request properties of
am i making sense
right because a locale is basically a
collection
of potentially up to four parameters for
the language the location the script and
a variant potentially
sander is suggesting some kind of
mechanism for date string where you can
give a string and then you give its
input language association arrow its
output language association
yeah i mean we basically be able to do
that in in from date string
we'd basically there's a date format
option
that exists for anything that generates
date objects
so you could say you know the second
argument of from date string
is the input so for the parameters
associated with the input string
and the date format option is the output
or alternatively we might want to
support like in word translation
something which is literally a um
aerodynamic
yeah yeah does not seem unreasonable
okay but but but i understand the the
remaining issue is
you want to be able to do a local lookup
on the entity property object
right that was your main point francisco
yes
the that was the point you were making
right but also the fact that yes and
also the fact that you can
let's say create a local specification
because
it's i understand but we already dealt
with that and talking about it
okay i understand but so
i mean
it seems to me that the way we should
think about this is by having a local
open close so to speak
i'm not sure right
i don't think this is right i think what
we want is the specification of a local
not local data this doesn't do us any
good
right unless unless what you imagine is
that local data returns an association
which you then feed to other things
the alternative is a symbolically
specified locale
that will be turned into
yeah i'm not sure i have to go to do
another live stream actually
um and i need to go so i
maybe you guys can can do one more
iteration on this
um and uh
yeah i mean i think we have enough to to
start working on the
the dates part of this and then sort out
do we want local as a first class object
or do we want to use
entities okay sounds good okay for those
watching these live streams i am
signed up to do a q a about business and
innovation
and then uh at the top of the hour after
that we are coming back
to let me see what is it today um
uh language completeness and consistency
meeting
um so thanks everybody for this meeting